non monsieur orelsan
celui qu'on appelle et nous mêmes
d'alençon a annoncé toujours pas comment
il doit le prendre
alors qu drame aux apparences vous êtes
rappeur dit contrairement aux apparences
parce que vous êtes blanc pas très
musclé vous ne voulez pas indiqué la
france
et vous savez conjuguer les verbes au
présent de l'indicatif
et c'est très bien bravo aux revenus de
caen ouais votre mère était prof votre
père directeur de collège à vos débuts
dans le rap vous avez préféré dire que
votre mère était en taule et que votre
père deal et du crack j'imagine
j'ai pas menti non mais moi même j'étais
pas très crédible quoi qu'il arrive et à
fallait il a fallu jouer cartes sur
table et
vous avez fait des études de management
alors je continue je suis en train de
[ __ ] en l'air votre carrière j'ai fait
la dose que
ces missions d'un mec t'es super vénère
parce que sa mère l'a quittée bon alors
évidemment les gens hurlaient en
entendant ça sur votre grand mère qui a
très bien compris qu'elle et son mari
elle a dit tu vois jean quelques fois tu
m'énerves et j'ai envie de titres
anglais mais c'est juste ce qu'il
raconte
c'était l'histoire d'un mec qu envoyer
un mail ouais ouais donc en fait
s'il ya vraiment je trouve que cote
quand on a besoin d'exprimer des
émotions assez violente c'est mieux de
le faire en chanson que par n'importe
quel autre moyen alors ni [ __ ] ni
soumises les chiennes de garde ont moins
bien compris clic que votre grand mère
est toujours en procès mais j'ai gagné
deux procès sur trois est de rester le
premier procès l'appel de l'annoncé en
cassation il faut dire que ségolène
royal vous a fait déprogrammé des
francofolies et le pire c'est que j'ai
soutenu frédéric lefebvre ça c'est break
être soutenu par frédéric lefebvre n'en
vaut mieux pas tout je veux dire quoi il
y avait beaucoup de girouette un coup
j'étais soutenu à droite après à gauche
après à droite alors elles savent de
tichy ce soir non pas pour un disque
mais pour un film ça s'appelle comment
c'est loin vous l'interprétez avec votre
complice grainge vous l'avez coréalisé
avec christophe offenstein alors le
pitch à caen
aurait les granges galère pour écrire
leur premier album de rap leurs
producteurs la mettre une grosse
pression et leur donne une deadline 24
heures pour sortir une chanson voilà
mais leur légendaire procrastination les
potes envahissant les problèmes de
couple ne vont pas aller faire avancer
voilà c'est des mecs qui font de la
musique depuis dix ans et un jour ils se
rendent compte qu'ils ont jamais fini
une seule chanson
c'est terrible ouais c'est un buddy
movie quoi ces deux antihéros de deux
losers vous buvez grange va voir des put
enfin bon c'est un bon gros boulot faut
le dire parce que vous êtes à la fois
scénariste réalisateur comédien
compositeur cheka par orson welles et
les charlots ouais t'as j'adore les
charlots
personne n'avait fait ça on vous en fait
vous avez pris tous les jobs pour être
nominé dans le plus de catégories
possibles aux césars j'imagine moi je
l'espère était pas à l'abri d'avoir un
prix je vais te dire moi ok non tu sais
si tu veux dîner avec moi un soir
ça a dû pouvoir maintenant aussi tard
alors vous êtes vous une sorte de héros
pour la génération qui demande toute la
journée sur un canapé en regardant la
télé ou son smartphone vous allez
convaincre comment ces gens là de sortir
de chez eux pour aller voir votre film
piraté n'importe où les films que j'ai
moi-même
autour de l'accord le pire de tout c'est
que j'ai une bonne critique dans
télérama c'est un film d'une sensualité
hilarante moderne et ambre pas fou
actuellement ce que j'aurais dit en
sortie de banc mais c'est bien normal
c'est vrai qu'il ya unité de lieu unité
de temps et unité d'inaction
j'ai bien regardé comment luc besson
faisait ses films et j'ai fait le
contraire
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux